now I've been very curious about
why I feel so much better when I drink
carbonated water versus regular water
and I didn't know the answer until very
recently so I'm going to share this with
you as well as some other fascinating
things related to
CO2 carbon dioxide so whether you're
drinking soda water Club water seltzer
water Lacroix or any type of carbonated
water this relates to
CO2 because the way they carbonate It Is
by adding this gas CO2 into the water
which does make it slightly acidic
because it turns into carbonic acid
unless it's stored a little bit
differently as these bicarbonates in
water but regardless of that when I
drink carbon and water I just feel more
hydrated
my digestion is better
and I just I feel better I feel more
relaxed when I drink carbonated water so
if you happen to see some other videos
related to carbon dioxide I mentioned
this one effect called the bore effect b
o h r that is a condition that relates
to CO2 in other words or oxygen to be
absorbed into your cells into the
tissues
takes CO2 which is very counterintuitive
you would think logically if you got
more air okay less CO2 you would have
more oxygen but that's not true it takes
that CO2 to slightly adjust the ph and
drop it a little bit and make it
slightly more acidic to allow the oxygen
to be released this is why if you
hyperventilate in a panic attack you're
getting too much O2 and not enough CO2
and you can't breathe right and then you
start breathing in a paper bag and you
get more CO2 and now you can breathe in
fact you can actually create a hypoxic
state that is a state of lowered oxygen
by depriving the tissues of CO2 which is
very interesting because normally you
would think hypoxia low oxygen means too
much CO2 which can occur
but you can also create that same
situation with not enough CO2 so CO2 is
really essential in the homeostasis of
oxygen absorption now in Europe they
actually have these sauna baths that are
carbonated they call them carbonated
spas or baths where they pump the CO2
into this water and apparently it's
great for all sorts of circulatory
problems like problems with your
vascular system especially something
called peripheral vascular disorders
they even use it for diabetic wounds and
to decrease the rate of getting an
amputation where they cut off the feet I
mean it can actually improve that by
increasing microvascular circulation so
basically CO2 increases blood flow it's
even used as the therapy after someone
gets a stroke and they have this hypoxic
low oxygen
State because the CO2 helps that oxygen
go deep into the cells now I could not
find any research on drinking carbonated
water okay in that relating to an
improved Health but I have found
parallel research and all the things I'm
talking about and I'll include that down
below and one state I found there was a
significant increase in the
parasympathetic nervous system
activation by increasing CO2 that's the
system that counters the flutter fight
mode it's the system that helps your
healing and your digestion and your
ability to sleep and the device they use
to measure the parasympathetic is what I
used in my practice which is technology
called heart rate variability let's take
a look at some other things that I found
related to this if you take a normal
cell inside
and then you take a cancer cell and we
look at the pH of each one a cancer cell
actually is more alkaline now the
outside of the cell more acidic because
of all the byproducts from lactic acid
things like that but the inside of the
cell is more alkaline than a normal cell
which is very interesting especially as
it relates to CO2 and I couldn't find
any information on this but think about
this when you deprive a tissue of CO2
you actually can develop alkalosis that
is a state of being too alkaline so
without that CO2 turning into carbonic
acid you can develop an overly alkaline
State and then I wanted to figure out is
there any relationship or any
significant Improvement in shrinking
tumors or stopping the spread of cancer
by increasing CO2 and I found a bunch of
research which is also very interesting
which I'll include down below so
apparently CO2 is a significant potent
anti-tumor
gas it has the ability to inhibit
metastasis which is interesting as well
as inducing apoptosis which causes the
cancer cells to commit suicide it also
inhibits this very interesting Gene
that's involved in this switching
mechanism between a normal cell
and it turning into cancer that gene is
called h i f Dash Alpha which is
involved in hypoxia now this probably
doesn't make sense unless you understand
that CO2 allows oxygen to go into the
tissues and as bad as hypoxia is it can
be created by a lowered amount of CO2 as
well as lowered oxygen levels but also
there's this CO2 connection that is very
interesting I had this thing in my mind
where if we just flood the body with
oxygen right we'll be able to kill the
cancer and we can prevent cancer but
apparently the CO2 is another key factor
that we cannot ignore like even in a
thunderstorm
um you can probably breathe better and
if you ever wanted to know why well
apparently there's a lot more CO2 in the
air after a thunderstorm than there is
when there's not a thunderstorm going on
also you'll actually get more oxygen
into your tissues if you breathe through
your nose not your mouth when you're
sleeping as well as when you exercise
there's another interesting natural bath
like the Springs if you go to the hot
springs and at first we might think
there's a lot of minerals involved that
are helping us but guess what there's a
significant amount of CO2 in Hot Springs
which could be the reason why you feel
better and you're more relaxed now
they're even using CO2 in various creams
for hydration to your skin and better
circulation and blood flow which is
another interesting
piece of this puzzle and the last point
about the CO2 is that CO2 apparently is
a potent anti-inflammatory so I just
wanted to increase your awareness on the
CO2 this carbon dioxide thing as well as
carbonated water and this could be the
reason which I think it is of why you
may feel better if you consume more
carbonated water and what I have is I
have a little carbonated machine that
makes my water carbonated so I take my
spring water and I carbonate it and
that's what I drink but since we're on
the topic of water you haven't seen this
video I think you should watch it
there's definitely more information
to be known about water and I put it up
right here